We've evolved to recognize color and
shapes at a very basic level.
Just as we saw how shape and
arrangement can tell us a lot.
We also infer information from
an item's color and appearance.
Color can tell us if
a particular food looks ripe or
rotten, if we should stop or go or
if our battery is running low.
It can be used to direct attention or
imply hierarchy and structure.
Material design encourages
you the app developer
to embrace bold
purposeful uses of color.
Not just for aesthetics, but
to make your app easier to use.
The material design color pallet
includes a set of primary and
secondary colors that can
be used across devices.
One note on the material pallet is
that it is in no way restrictive.
These aren't the only allowed colors.
If you have established brand colors,
use them.
It is however a great hand
picked starting point
that you can use to get going.